hello I am Kristen Landis P Belvoir I am
a medical laboratory scientist trained
as a cancer biologist and my PhD is in
cancer biology so I have some background
in both the ability to perform
laboratory testing and understand some
of that and vanesa necessity to have
laboratory testing and also to interpret
it very much from the cancer biology
world I'm an assistant professor at
Oakland University in Rochester Michigan
and I'm here today to talk about very
specifically molecular diagnostics and
cancer and how we can use those
molecular diagnostic tools to not only
just detect but also to help diagnose
and these part gnostic indicators as
well first off I'd like to start this
discussion we're talking about
carcinogenesis I know that this is a
varied population of people taking part
in this bio conference and I know that
I've got people on all ends of the
spectrum so some of the first few slides
may be remedial or they may be on the
advanced side depending on where you're
coming from um a side note I am getting
over a little bit of a head cold so if I
start talking a bit I do have my cough
drops handy but that's the beauty of
doing these online talks right we can
keep our germs all to ourselves so my
virus stays with me and all of you get
to stay healthy um regardless when we're
talking about carcinogenesis and
discussing how a cell actually becomes a
cancer so this is an important point
when we start talking about the
diagnostic issues in the laboratory
testing that we can do because we need
to be able to identify how these these
cells are actually having been
transformed into a cancer cell so
carcinogenesis also known as creation of
cancer is a process and a process is a
process of normal cells being
transformed into cancer cells there are
three phases to this process of
carcinogenesis starting with initiate
a cancer gene is going to somehow be
altered in the process of initiation and
this alteration is going to either be a
large chromosomal change or an
individual nucleotide or a small region
of nucleotides that is altered when this
event occurs if we don't have the
appropriate DNA repair mechanisms in
place to fix this particular alteration
and it stays within the genome of that
cell and then any subsequent progeny of
that cell and so we say that this is an
irreversible event when we have
initiated that cancer cell by causing
some kind of alteration the next phase
of carcinogenesis is promotion and
promotion essentially leads to the
clonal expansion of that cancer cell
meaning that that cell is able to
multiply it has mitotic capability and
can go through multiple divisions to
show that we end up seeing that same
mutational change that occurs during the
process of initiation in subsequent
cells the environment of the cell has to
be perfect
for promotion to move forward in that if
you change the environment of the cell
take away the factor that has allowed
for that cell to be able to multiply
then you have stopped the ability of
promotion so this phase of
carcinogenesis is reversible the last
phase of carcinogenesis is progression
in which we have we can see accumulated
changes in cancer cells multiple
mutations chromosomal instability and
once a cell has achieved this this last
phase of progression it has basically
fallen into an irreversible mutational
event and it cannot go back and Ruppert
and have any DNA repair mechanisms fixed
what has happened so at the bottom in
this lovely image you can see that we
start with an initiated cell here in
orange and that initiated cell has
acquired some kind of a chromosomal
change or a small mutation if that cell
is allowed to multiply then we can see
many copies of that in the process of
promotion and then
we have a style that has acquired
additional changes which allow for that
cell to then goes through the processes
of progression and make many many many
more copies of itself ultimately that
came into a metastasis this is pertinent
to both hematologic malignancies and
solid tumors and so this talk is going
to follow both hematologic malignancies
and some of those tumors that are
associated with some with organs as well
when we're looking for these changes
that are occurring during this process
of initiation and ultimately what leads
to progression what is being acid for
our chromosomal alterations and DNA
alterations those are our two flavors
for the genetic changes that are going
to be seen the chromosomal alterations
are either going to be unbalanced or
balanced and I'll describe what that
means in just a moment and the DNA
alterations are going to be reflected in
many different types but single
nucleotide changes small insertions or
small evolutions generally speaking or
what is seen when we have these changes
leading to carcinogenesis
first I will describe some of the
chromosomal alterations many of which
you're probably familiar with but a but
a chromosomal alterations can can be
categorized as either an unbalanced or a
balanced change to the to the overall
genome in that particular cell we can
see on large regions that are either
deleted or duplicated in either of those
instances those who be considered
unbalanced chromosomal changes because
you had either gained or lost a large
portion of the chromosome of the total
genome and so the total genome is now
unbalanced compared to how it was
previously alternatively we have
balanced chromosomal changes in the
categories of generally speaking
inversions or translocations the
inversions are our and translocations
generally speaking are allowing for the
same amount of total genetic material to
remain present in the cell but its
location
Chinn within the chromosome has changed
and because of that chromosome the
location of what has created our new
combinations of DNA sequences leading to
combinations potentially of genes and
how those genes are going to be encoded
for so some examples of this are and for
this as an example on the top here you
can see that there is a deletion that
has occurred if we have this total
chromosome here that is that's passed
from showing all these different regions
on the long arm and on the short arm of
this chromosome then you can see that
over on the other side we've lost some
region we've lost my earrings a little
bit off here but we've lost this region
between chromosome
sorry genes 3 & 2 of these regions of
genes 3 & 2 we've lost that region it's
a deletion it is an unbalanced
chromosomal change a simple
translocation is where there is just
going to be in one region of one
chromosome here on this end that is
going to end on this end as well there's
going to be these two regions that are
going to flip-flop or or rather I am
speaking myself it with a simple
translocation we just have this one
region on the end moving on to the other
end of one other chromosome a reciprocal
translocation is when the two regions
flip-flop I apologize for my speaking
there so here you can see that this
region this short region on the end of
this chromosome and this somewhat larger
region on this chromosome have changed
locations as opposed to one large region
moving to the end of one chromosome in
either case with translocations also
with inversions there is just a change
in a location of information but all of
the information 40-odd for that cell is
still present whereas on the top with
our deletions there's actually a loss of
genetic information so deletions are
only problematic when we're considering
tumor suppressor genes what are very
common in in solid tumors is that we see
duplications and so we can end up seeing
large regions of one chromosome being
accidentally copied if you will and
having multiple alleles
I'll show up at one particular gene
where we were only supposed to have
expression at one at one level of that
gene by having multiple duplications or
multiple copies of that gene we can end
up seeing much higher gene expression
and that can promote a cell towards the
towards the progressive phenotype of
what we see in a the last phase of
carcinogenesis
so with those translocations if it's if
it's balanced then we have this what
we're seeing is a one segment of a
chromosome is being attached to another
it's it's a reciprocal then we have an
exchange between these two regions how
this occurs with these with these
translocations is that there has to be
some kind of a chromosomal break and
there has to be there then some kind of
mechanism of DNA repair to have happened
to actually fuse those ends of
chromosomes and those regions so again
this is not a change in the total amount
this is just a change in the position
within the genome so here you can see
with this example chromosome 22 and 2 if
you're thinking along the lines of a
it's logical in see if you could
substitute maybe chromosome number 9
here if you've ever heard of that
translocation and we might have some
sort of an environmental agent that is
going to something exogenous to the cell
it's going to be causing these DNA
double strand breaks when these DNA
double strand breaks occur we end up
having these reactive ends to the
chromosomes and those reactive ends are
problematic because if they're not put
back on in the exact same position they
can DNA repair mechanisms can recognize
these is just being purely reactive and
all we need to fix this and when and in
doing so what may happen is we have non
homologous chromosomes with different
ends that were then were originally
supposed to be there the total amount of
the genome stays the same but what is
what has the the Dean's sequence the DNA
sequence has now been altered and moved
from one chromosome to the next on these
chromosomal alterations the ultimate
effect of having inversions take place
having reciprocal translocations or
simple translocations what happens is we
can have one of three different things
as the outcome essentially fusion genes
a position effect or a breakpoint effect
a fusion gene is where there is going to
be on some coding region of one gene
connected to a coding region of another
gene and when those two coding regions
come together that creates a new
function for that for that gene bet DNA
sequence so this is considered to be a
gain of function mutation by having
these translocations or inversions take
place when we have a position effect
there is just a rearrangement of some of
the regulatory elements that are
allowing for gene expression to take
place and a breakpoint effect is where
there is a loss of one particular region
or another this will come into play and
you can see how how all three of these
effects at the chromosomal level will
play out when we talk about oncogenes
and tumor suppressor genes and how
certain genes are going to be increased
in their expression where other genes
are going to be decreased in their
expression on the top you see that we
have a position effect in that there is
the coding region for a gene and having
followed a simple translocation a
reciprocal translocation or an inversion
what has happened is by flipping some of
those DNA segments around or moving them
to other places in the genome one gene
in this case gene B the coding region as
indicated by these sort of larger
thicker rectangles that's the coding
region for the gene is now going to be
in proximity to a promoter for a
different gene the promoter for gene a
may be a highly active promoter with
enhancer sequences bound by activator
proteins that push transcription at a
much faster rate than say gene B is
supposed to have
um and in the next example you can see
that there are fusion genes being
produced in which we have the normal
coding sequence here for gene B and the
normal coding sequence here for gene a
excuse me um having been disrupted and
it's a little bit faint on this image
but there's a line right here to
indicate that there is a break that has
occurred along this particular line so
the coding sequence for this region here
on gene a is then going to be fused to
the coding sequence of this gene region
unguent be and what the outcome is then
is these are these fusion genes down
below that are showing that lots arrows
here that are showing that we have these
new these new sequences having been put
together this can actually completely
disrupt a gene from being able to be
functional or it may generate a totally
new function for a for the gene the gene
expression or the the transcript
ultimately that can be translated into a
protein doing something different than
it had before and lastly with the
breakpoint effect what is seen is that
there is some kind of a damage to a
particular gene possibly when we had a
simple translocation take place where
one large segment of a chromosome has
moved to another and in doing so this
large segment here has gone often to
oblivion to a different chromosome and
it has changed where this total gene
sequence would have been and so now this
this gene down below is no longer going
to be functional we've deleted the
coding region for that particular gene
and we don't have the ability for it to
be able to do what it normally was
supposed to do this can be a problem
meeting towards the loss of tumor
suppressor genes especially so those are
those large chromosomal changes that we
may see happening but what may also
occur especially in the context of solid
tumors is that we see individual
nucleotide changes or small changes
within the DNA sequence or DNA
alterations all of the chromosomal
changes that were just described
are predominantly observed in
hematologic malignancies and smaller DNA
alterations can be seen in hematologic
malignancies but these when there are
point mutations or small changes in the
DNA sequence typically that is what is
found in a solid tumor at home
oncological order so there are a number
of different DNA alterations some of
which are spontaneous some of which are
induced spontaneous mutations are those
that occur within the genome on a
regular basis what all experiencing
spontaneous mutations all the time but
we have DNA repair mechanisms to fix
those mutations whenever they occur so
just in problems with DNA replication in
a mitotically active cell if DNA
polymerase makes a mistake
it does have exonuclease activity to
identify that mistake cut it out and fix
it
but if it makes a mistake and doesn't
actually notice that there's a mistake
there then it gets locked in the genome
and that's what's considered to be a
spontaneous mutation and it can be the
the categories below can can be
spontaneous otherwise an induced
mutation would be those that are
exogenous to the cell UV light exposure
to various chemicals viruses all kinds
of different things where a cell may be
exposed to something from outside of
itself and that exposure causes any of
the kinds of mutations or alterations
that we see below so missense mutations
if you hadn't thought about some of
these terms in a while just in case a
missense mutation is a a base change
that was going to encode for a different
amino acid than normally would have been
included for this is sometimes not
problematic if it is an amino acid that
has a very very similar structure is the
original amino acid if it's a completely
different amino acid or it's an amino
acid that's in the position of that of
the protein that has a very purposeful
function along the lines of enzymatic
activity then by losing that amino acid
you have destroyed the function of it
and dying
as an example a nonsense mutation is one
that where a single base change can
change a normal coat on to a termination
photon or maybe that there are a series
of base changes that changes a normal
proton to a termination put on if this
occurs very early on in the protein
sequence then the step pull down occurs
really on and the DNA sequence what I
should have said then the the mRNA is
not going to be trans will be
transcribed with the but the protein
ultimately will not have translation
occur because it will will identify that
particular site as being don't bother
putting the next amino acid on we're
done here and then we end up having an
extremely truncated protein if any
protein can be made at all so because of
that these nonsense mutations are
particularly problematic when discussing
a lot of tumor suppressor genes is when
we lose tumor suppressor genes that it
is problematic to the generation of
cancer insertions and deletions can
result in frame shifts and these frame
shifts change with the overall reading
frame is within a particular gene and
changed the that coding sequence when we
have these friendships it is going to be
that we are generating a whole new amino
acid sequence because it is small and
short insertions or deletions generally
speaking these have to occur in groups
of one or two four or five but not in
groups of three and in considering these
kinds of mutations what I've just
described are missing some tendons and
insertions and deletions that all occur
in coding sequences of genes but there
are plenty of other gene that plenty of
other alterations to DNA that can occur
that are not within the coding sequence
and if we have promoter mutations splice
site junctions five Prime and three
prime untranslated regions regulatory
elements all of these are ricans that
are not encoded for in the in the
translated protein but if we disrupt any
of these various sequences within a gene
we can drastically decrease or
increase its expression or I'll turn
jungle up the way that it ends up being
translated in the case of some of these
splice junction mutations and in either
case it is going to change the the
outcome for that gene all of this leads
to oncogenes and tumor suppressor genes
oncogenes are those genes that are going
to be turned on and are going to have
some kind of a gain of function they are
going to be genes that are going to be
very useful to promoting the
proliferation of a cell by turning on a
receptor that isn't supposed to be
turned on or turning on some sort of
regulatory element within the cell cycle
that allows for the cell to push through
the cell cycle when it shouldn't
normally do so so oncogenes are going to
our art are actually normal genes
initially they're called proto oncogenes
and they have a normal function within
the cell it is only when there has been
some kind of an alteration to that
proto-oncogene that it disrupts its
normal function leading it to an
oncogene and leaving it there for to
this new gain of function how proto
oncogenes can be activated are varied a
list of which is it's here viruses and
chromosomal translocations any kind of
amplification of genes point me to all
of these are going to potentially lead
to turning on a proto-oncogene into an
oncogene and as you can see below and in
this lovely image I have this little
yellow solitaire with green chromosomes
and there's a little green ball here
that represents a particular allele of a
of a particular gene sequence
gain-of-function mutations or in proto
oncogenes are typically dominant
mutations meaning that if that it just
one allele is altered and we can end up
seeing and so then we end up having this
one allele becoming altered by some sort
of DNA damaging agent we can see tumor
formation because of just one one single
allele certainly there has initially
being turned on certainly there has to
be a number of different changes to
genome within a cancer cell within a
cell for it to actually
a cancer cell but initially it is just a
single mutation to one of these proto
oncogenes that gets the process started
an example of how oncogenes may may
function is through receptor tyrosine
kinase a--'s and if you haven't thought
about signal transduction it's actually
kind of a useful thing to understand
when trying to dissect molecular
diagnostic mechanisms in in oncology so
initially when we have a ligand here in
purple in the presence of some
transmembrane receptors those receptors
dimerize and they become activated by a
number of different mechanisms this is
the basics of signal transduction here
that activation can then activate signal
transducing molecules proteins within
the cell that can then activate other
proteins and can activate potentially
transcription factors that can move into
the nucleus and it's binds to DNA and
recruit in with the help of some general
transcription factors recruit an RNA
polymerase to start the gene expression
and creation of an mRNA molecule that
can ultimately be translated into a
protein it is when any of these
mechanisms go wrong that we disrupt this
central dogma of molecular biology DNA
can replicate itself DNA can be
transcribed into RNA and ultimately be
translated into protein if what happens
is there is an alteration in the
receptor maybe in the intracellular
portion of that receptor where it is
constitutively active then we end up
having this signal transduction cascade
moving forward without being regulated
there are a number of instances in which
any of those signal transducing
molecules found within the signal
transduction cascade are active without
being activated by the receptor there
are certain transcription factors that
might be activated without actually
having activation from outside in the
cytoplasm and ultimately up to the
surface of the cell so we can see
multiple places where signal
transduction goes awry and it is
molecular diagnostics that can be used
to help identify
these specific molecules that are known
to be altered in a number of different
cancers to help us identify and
personalize some of the medicines to be
used for for patients in the context of
oncogenes I've given you a couple of
tables and I've requested that these
slides be made into a PDF for your
visual interest afterward so that you
can have some of these some of this
information at your disposal notice for
what I've given you first there are
hematologic disorders and the next side
you can see that there are solids for my
disorders as well but notice that the
alteration that takes place for these
human slogic disorders is oftentimes
some kind of translocation
certainly there are point mutations and
certainly this is a very abbreviated
list but it would take 12 PowerPoint
slides to be able to put a limitation to
a list that you could actually look at
so this is just a short list and these
are some of the some of the molecules
that we can test for now to determine if
any patient has some of these
alterations and personalize their
medicine but you can see that the
disorder is listed on the right what the
alteration is is is in the middle and
the fusion gene or the alternative gene
for that matter is present here on the
left as an oncogene
likewise with solid tumors there are a
number of different changes that can
occur many many many different kinds of
changes but usually it is some kind of a
point mutation or an amplification less
likely that we have translocations
although they do happen but mostly that
we see an increased production of a
particular gene sequence being
transcribed into an RNA translated into
protein or a point mutation which
changes the effect of one particular
gene there are many many many different
point mutations for what I have listed
here there are some more well-known
examples than there are of others but
there are so many it would be exhausted
to be able to whisk them all the tumors
that some of these are associated with
you'll notice there are multiple
different tumors that that some of these
oncogenes
can be associated with it depends on the
source of the alteration and where that
cell first exists for which the solid
tumors we actually see those in so tumor
person's tumor suppressor genes would be
the SIP side to the oncogenes these are
going to be genes that are encoding for
proteins that will ultimately inhibit
cell proliferation by having some kind
of mutation or disruption of the coding
sequence what has happened is we lose or
at least reduce the function of any of
these tumor suppressor genes this is
what leads to cancer development and for
for these particular problems the
Knudsen two-hit hypothesis suggests that
one copy of one tumor suppressor gene
can be lost and it is a essentially a
recessive mutation that occurs there's a
second copy that can overcome the loss
of the first copy but well when we lose
the second copy we enter into the state
that's considered to be loss of
heterozygosity so both alleles of a
tumor suppressor gene must be altered we
can see inherited states where we
inherit one bad copy and then there's a
sporadic mutation that occurs to the
second bad copy otherwise there may be
two sporadic alterations that occur to
two separate to the two alleles of a
tumor suppressor gene this loss of
heterozygosity comes about when you look
at what a normal cell would look like it
has two homologous chromosomes that have
all of the gene sequence now that are
totally normal but at one particular
region a DNA damaging event and a
sporadic and the sporadic model would
cause some sort of a mutation at this
particular site but the second copy is
of that allele is still functional
it's still present so this cell the
genome for that cell would be considered
to be heterozygous there's one good copy
there's one bad copy so this cell or the
heterozygous itself and is therefore not
problematic it is only when a second
event has occurred as is shown in this
third cell type that this cell is no
longer considered to be heterozygous
both copies of this allele have been
altered and therefore this cell has
acquired two bad copies and is now
homozygous for that particular allele
sequence so it has lost the state of
being heterozygous and we do not have
that particular tumor suppressor acting
in the manner that it should and we
therefore will see tumor formation on
the example I gave for oncogenes I gave
you this image of signal transduction
certainly it's not the only way that we
can see on oncogenes prints generally
speaking a pretty good model with tumor
suppressor genes a pretty good model
would be to represent the cell cycle and
any of the molecules that are involved
in pushing a cell from one phase to the
next throughout the cell cycle can be
altered and can be problematic in
leading to be occurrence of cancer in a
human so logic malignancy or a solid
tumor so if you recall your cell cycle
central dogma of molecular biology in
the cell cycle good times right there
has to be some kind of a stimulus that
would be here and that can move the cell
from a resting state in g0 into g1 or
gap one and there are a number of
different molecules I just listed a few
here but there are several molecules
hundreds of molecules that are important
for allowing for a cell to actually
progress through g1 and into s the DNA
jam damaged checkpoint shown here or
restriction one that that particular
checkpoint is very very important and
p53 is the molecule that is probably the
most important for allowing for a cell
to progress into synthesis S phase and
checking to make sure the DNA is in its
perfect state and if we don't have a
perfect state of DNA then
into replication of the chromosomes
cannot ensure that we have DNA
polymerase acting the way that it should
and allowing for a perfect copy of the
genome in its original state and you can
see that p53 acts in many different
places as well
certainly a p53 isn't the only tumor
suppressor gene it just happens to be
the most well-known but there's a few
others that are listed here and several
others that that I have listed for you
here
so along the lines of tumor suppressor
genes what we saw with compared to
oncogenes what we saw was there were
amplifications there were point
mutations there were translocations
along lines and tumor suppressor genes
we're typically observed are some kind
of deletions maybe promoter methylation
in which there the CPG Islands that
might be found just upstream of a
promoter sequence are turned off and do
not allow the regulatory sequences that
would allow for gene transcription to
commence at the appropriate rate can be
shut down and then there might be large
regions out of deletions in large
portions of chromosomes all of which are
going to be leading to the loss of
particular genes or didn't the change in
the sequence of other genes and the
hematologic disorders are listed on to
the right here in regard to solid tumors
as I mentioned p53 happens to be a very
common one but you can see that the
mutations are also very similar as what
we see in him hematology disorders in
that there's lots of deletions there's a
few more point mutations that are
observed in in solid tumors but there's
certainly some point mutations that are
observed in humans logic researchers as
well and some of the solid tumors are
listed here again this is not a complete
list it is just some examples of some
very common tumor suppressor genes and
as we saw earlier on drew genes that
that are known to be altered and a few
of the ways that we can alter them yes
there's point mutations how many point a
shion's therefore any given gene you can
know of ten to 100 different mutations
or maybe just one too many to be able to
list so now what all of this leads to
now that we know how we got our genes
and our own
Changez now we're going to actually
start looking for them and it's
molecular diagnostics that are going to
help us to determine whether or not we
have the presence of these ankle genes
or the loss of these tumor suppressor
genes and help to determine whether or
not a patient is going to benefit from
any given therapy we first have to be
able to detect the presence or absence
of these genes so for hematologic
malignancies lymphoid clonality can be
considered both hematologic and solid
tumor depending on who you're talking to
but I will describe a little bit of
lymphoid clonality but certainly with
the detection and monitoring of fusion
genes and acquired mutations this is
where we're definitely going to be
looking at the hematologic beside but
there are far more acquired mutations
that are going to be seen in the solid
tumor world ultimately what an important
point but not everybody is aware of is
the concept of minimal residual disease
especially in hematologic disorders we
see we're able to do much less with this
in solid tumors
simply because of the invasiveness of
being able to look for those solid
tumors and the hematologic disorder you
draw some blood or pretend to do a bone
marrow tap it's so invasive that can be
far less invasive than considerably
speaking considering what to biopsy a a
solid tumor and then there's a few other
things that we'll just discuss as well
leading to this whole idea of molecular
diagnostics so one point clonality
refers to some the presence of an
hematologic disorder or some people may
refer to a lymph node as being a solid
tumor as well it depends on who you're
talking to
hematologist tend to think of all these
things circulating and so they're going
to be upset he massage of disorders what
what is a normal event in pain
lymphocytes is this gene rearrangement
and this is a very very good thing to
have gene rearrangements take place
because that allows for diversity of our
immunoglobulin genes and t-cell receptor
so that we can fight off infection and
we can use the context of lymphoid
clonality to to help detect leukemias
and lymphomas and to monitor them as
they have progressed through a therapy
and ultimately look for whether or not
specific rearrangements have taken place
to help this room the prognosis my my
little picture here up above showing all
of these different colored circles
represents a poly colon cell population
of lymphocytes and in any given human at
any given time generally speaking we
would see a varied population of cells
because we've got all these different
cells with different rearrangements of
antibody learned genes and also of
t-cell receptor genes in the context of
a leukemia or a lymphoma
what ends up happening is they end up
seeing many many many copies of one
particular gene arrangement being
expressed on the cell phone allottee
does not necessarily equal malignancy
however when you see a large population
of cells that contain the exact same
gene rearrangement it certainly takes
makes when you take pause and wonder if
this is actually a clone of lymphocytes
that is going to be problematic for the
patient and leading to a cancer
situation how to test for that lymphoid
clonality would be to identify very
specific regions that are that are known
and use primers specific to those
regions so in looking at antibody one
genes we know of the variable diversity
in joining regions and then a few other
on gene sequences VI G H K and L and
then there's also the T cell receptor
loci meaning to the various different
chains that that will generate a T cell
receptor the image that is shown here is
a polymerase chain reaction followed by
gel electrophoresis capillary gel
electrophoresis and I'll briefly explain
that in just a moment
but in a normal poly criminal population
an individual that does not have a
Leukemia Lymphoma then what we see is
this all of these
little Peaks that are associated with
many many many different gene
rearrangements in this case of the ith
gene and down below here this is just
one example looking at the the t-cell
receptor gamma chain and you can see
that there are many many different
populations of cells with different
rearrangements of that gene looking at a
clonal population you see one peak so
that would be representative of the
previous slide where we saw all these
blue balls essentially blue circles
representing an accumulation or a clone
of those lymphocytes and this is
problematic because it's suggesting that
we have far too many cells that have the
exact same gene rearrangement and
therefore there is a mitotically active
precursor that is has gone a little bit
wild and is making many many to pop many
many to many copies of itself and what
is the outcome there is a clone how
these images came about is through a
polymerase chain reaction or a PCR in
which the sequence that is to be
identified must be known and so that we
considered that the patient's template
their DNA there have to be primers
involves dntps the individual a's and
t's c's and g's tac limb arrays and
certainly some buffers but all of this
has to come together and we would then
melt this double strand of DNA allow for
a primer to bind to a specific region
that we know to that we'll try and do
assay and then in the loom of all of
these other components then tact one
areas can extend that that region that
we've allow the primer to binds to it
tackling rays must recognize
double-stranded DNA which is why we need
to have a primer first and then it can
extend and move onward outward and
extend out this sequence and we can get
many many many copies of that and if you
haven't thought about PCR in a while you
can start off with one copy of your
template DNA and have an exponential
number of copies depending on how many
cycles that you allow for
the reaction to take place in capillary
gel electrophoresis there is actually
oftentimes polyacrylamide that is going
to be found inside a very very very
skinny capillary tube and it is but the
DNA has allowed to after it has gone
through a polymerase chain reaction the
sample is then passed through this
capillary tube and through a current and
where these sequences end up within
within the tube we can then measure and
detect where these different Peaks occur
in the detection of fusion genes so that
was mindful in allottee moving on toward
the detection of fusion genes these
fusion genes are going to be very much
associated with the activation of proto
oncogenes or the generation of new
oncogenes oftentimes the detection of
these fusion genes of these proto
oncogenes is going to be performed by
using real-time PCR or also known as
real-time reverse transcriptase PCR and
it's these fusions that we are trying to
identify to look by using this this
particular method a reverse
transcriptase real-time PCR can be
followed in real-time but what first has
to happen is we have to generate an RNA
see identify an RNA sequence from the
sample this is kind of tricky because
RNAs are very easily degraded but in
getting one of these RNAs a primer to
that RNA oftentimes at the poly a tail
of that RNA is going to be exposed to
the an enzyme called reverse
transcriptase which will then create an
rna-dna hybrid of the initial original
RNA molecule the RNA can then be
degraded so this RNA portion can then be
eliminated in a number of different ways
using an enzyme called RNA h or using
high alkali and allow for a primer to
bind to the single-stranded DNA
that remains and in the presence of the
enzyme DNA polymerase or Tecton race we
can then generate a double-stranded copy
of DNA that double-stranded copy of DNA
is going to be detected by a number of
different assays there are a number of
different dyes that can be used to
detect whether or not a particular
sequence of DNA happens to be present
from that original mrna molecule so
cyber green and Eva green are two very
commonly used fluorescent molecules to
to check that the more frequent language
used our hybridization probes and the
most common of which one is the sorry my
arrows kind of supposed to hear my
arrows a little off the tack man at
assay is the most common commonly used
real-time PCR assay but there are
certainly several others that I've
listed here so essentially what happens
is there's a probe that is going to be
attached to the DNA molecule and that
probe is going to have two ends one of
which contains a a sourcing molecule and
a punching molecule and when that probe
is allowed to bind to the DNA in the
presence of DNA polymerase it will be
displaced or or chopped up depending on
which assay is going to be used in
either case if the probe has bound to a
very specific sequence and is then
removed the the fluorescent molecule is
then able to actually fluoresce in the
presence of light and the quencher is no
longer in close proximity to allow for
for the blocking about fluorescence and
so we can see in a real-time PCR assay
or a real-time reverse transcriptase
assay we see fluorescence and we see
many many copies of fluorescence and you
can see an increase in the fluorescence
depending on how many copies of that
particular gene sequence we have this is
a commonly used mechanism to detect the
bcr-abl fusion protein from the
translocation of 9:22 and CML
chronic myelogenous leukemia and
a number of different common variants
that of that particular fusion that can
be identified it's also used in a
massage exciting to look for vco2 IgH
translocations from the translation of
chromosome 14 and 18 and follicular
lymphoma
it is certainly used in some humans
sorry it's all the tumor malignancies as
well but these are very very commonly
used in these two particular
malignancies essentially what happens is
as the fluorescence is generated there
is a threshold that must be crossed and
upon crossing that threshold we can
quantify how many copies of the
particular gene sequence we are seeing
in an individual and then that can be
converted back into a standard curve and
we can and get an actual number of
copies for a particular gene sequence to
detect fusion genes on in another
context we might see the use of
karyotyping which is the sort of
standard for looking at chromosomes to
look for large additions or relations of
translocations or what might be used is
fish fluorescence in situ hybridization
in which we are looking for structural
changes by using some of these
fluorescent markers but fish is a very
specific probe as opposed to karyotyping
when you're looking at the whole genome
you're using fish really to look for
very specific sequences and what's
what's used is a flora for a DNA probe
that has a floral floor that can bind to
a complementary sequence of DNA and then
fluoresce once exposed to light and it
will only fluoresce if it is balanced to
a very specific sequence so in this case
it would need to be known that there has
that there is a lightweight
translocation that have taken place and
they're looking for that fusion gene
that would have been created because of
that translocation one nice feature
about fish is that we can also use dual
fusion fish to look for two different
colors or two different fluorescent
markers in the case of BCR Abel we can
look for one gene being encoded for and
greeing the other encoded for in red and
if there is a translocation that has
taken
place then you can see that there is a
layover and what is observed is yellow
because of this overlapping of the red
and green fluorescent probes and we're
actually being able to intensify that
fusion gene because of these probes that
binds to very specific sequences on
these large chromosomes where we're
using finish is most commonly and
hematologic malignancies but it can be
used in some solid tumors as well with
breast cancer and looking for on
her2/neu when fish can be used as well
as as well as a number of different
immunohistochemistry methods as well but
typically if we're if we're talking
about a molecular diagnostic tool we're
trying to look for the DNA not the
protein product and an immune has to
chemistry's looking for the protein
product so in use it by using fish there
are many different hematologic
malignancies fewer solid tumors that are
actually going to be using that but
those are all listed here for your
reference why fish is um useful
certainly it's because interno typing
you have to have metaphase chromosomes
and when it's finished you can use
interface chromosomes you don't have to
have cells that are able to divide so
you can do this on archive material
that's a very nice benefit it's much
faster and it's much more sensitive than
we can see with using karyotyping and
using two colors we can get much better
discrimination um it might be useful to
use fish initially to determine whether
or not we have the potential for a
translocation having taken place but
real-time rt-pcr is going to real ten
reverse transcriptase PTR pcr is
probably going to be used later on as a
confirmatory mechanism there are
commercially available fish probes for
all known translocations but certainly
there's other transportations that you
don't know about some problems with fish
is that they are informative to very
specific regions where if you're using
cytogenetics and karyotyping you can
look at the whole genome and so they are
currently only the
as an adjunct to on cytogenetics you
have to have a certain number of cells
that must be positive to be able to be
able to detect using fish any of these
changes and it is not as sensitive as is
real-time pcr we don't actually see real
real specific changes and you can't
detect any small changes you're having
to look for larger form so much changes
when you're using the fish so along the
lines of some of these salty
malignancies there are going to be
plenty of mutations within genes that
are not just when you'll be associated
with translocations and many of these
mutations are going to be changing
oncogenes or proto oncogenes there are
so many different methods I could not
possibly go through them all I've listed
a few of them here and these can be used
for both hematologic or solid tumor
malignancies
one of those is allele or mutation
specific PCR in which there are mutant
primers that are bound to a mutant
sequence or primers bound with a with a
sequence that will bind to the wild-type
sequence and depending on whether or not
one of those primers binds to the
sequence are not determines whether or
not a particular band size will be
observed after performing a PCR and a
gel electrophoresis so you can see that
the larger fragment size is a fragment
band as observed when you have the
mutant primers there as opposed to a
mismatch with being wild-type animals
likewise there are mechanisms to use
real-time PCR for these single mutations
as opposed to looking for just
translocations as we saw previously
again it is amusing these fluorescent
probes that are containing these common
sequences that contain both a quencher
and a reporter and whether or not that
quencher is going to be displaced in the
presence of these probes so having a
wild-type allele bound with a mutant
probe or a mutant allele bound with a
wild type of probe you have to know what
you're using can
chairman whether or not you're going to
be seen in fluorescence this is commonly
used with the jak 2 mutation that's
associated with many different
myeloproliferative neoplasms and it's
also used with several others b-raf is a
common one in melanoma and solid tumors
that can also be used again the
fluorescence has to cross the threshold
and you can actually quantify how many
of those incidences you have
high-resolution mount analysis is going
to be the incorporation of these probes
and then allowing them to bind and then
seeing how long it takes for them to
dissociate from from the gene sequence
if you have a perfect match it will take
much longer for the probes to dissociate
and then you will take longer for you to
be able to detect the fluorescence from
that dissociation so you can compare
wild-type sequences to mutant sequins to
detect whether or not a patient contains
either the wild type or the mutant
minimal residual disease is one of these
prognostic mechanisms that is very very
useful in hematologic disorders and it's
it's useful to to determine whether or
not a patient has any cell left over
after having been treated the name says
it all minimal residual disease what's
left over after treatment so any of the
tumor cells that might still be
circulating after the curative treatment
and these are very very useful for
predicting whether or not a patient has
relapse or whether or not a therapy is
working so since these are with
circulating cells they can be less
useful in solid tumor malignancies
except for when those tumors have
metastasized to distant sites if you are
detecting those solid tumor cells in the
peripheral blood then likely you are
still seeing minimal residual disease
where this theory comes from as the
cancer stem cell theory and that there
are cells that act as progenitor like
cells that act as terminally
differentiated cells and that are going
to happen maintain some characteristics
of those within a cancer cell so when we
give an individual some sort of a
therapeutic regimen then we can see that
the met vast majority of mitotically
active cells are going to be
eliminated but there are some resistant
cancer stem cells that are likely to
have escaped that therapeutic regimen
and therefore that's what it is that we
are trying to be able to detect this has
been described in breast cancer cells
after conventional treatment treatment
and has also been described in a number
of different hematologic malignancies
especially the five key - milo
dysplastic syndromes in which there are
specific cell types that are resistant
to chemotherapy ticks and remain behind
and so that we say a patient has
maintained this state of minimal
residual disease those tumor cells can
be detected in a number of different
places in the blood especially but
certainly in some body fluid as well
using traditional imaging and
biochemical methods you can detect one
in 100,000 non tumor cells but using
some of the molecular methods are able
to detect one in 10 million 90 results
it's far more sensitive that you have to
have some kind of a cancer specific
marker a leukemia specific marker or a
solid tumor specific marker that is
found in all of the cells and it's going
to remain within all of those cells and
it should also be a marker that's unique
to each individual
and then you can use several the methods
that we've learned to discuss to detect
that on post transplantation chimerism
is essentially for those individuals
receiving bone-marrow transplants and it
is looking for gene sequences that are
found in some of the donor cells found
in the recipient cells and looking to
see whether or not we end up having a
mixed chimera for one of these
individuals what is oftentimes being
tested for are some short tandem repeats
or some other low side but oftentimes
these short tandem repeats which r35
these pairs sometimes a little bit
longer that are repeated over and over
and over again in one short region what
can be done is a polymerase chain
reaction followed by a capillary gel
electrophoresis to look for these
various peaks on the top you can see
that we have a recipient that has two
different Peaks
than does the
so after we can see with the donor that
has some these these two alleles being
informative alleles that we know that
we're going to be looking for those in
the recipient after transplantation for
this individual at the bottom and post
transplantation we're seeing all four
alleles which means that there are still
some of the patient cells remaining as
well as the donor cells and that really
needs to be just the donor cells that
are going to be present if we know that
the transplant a bone-marrow transplant
has taken place so this is just one
other tool that we can use molecular
diagnostics to be able to test that
sorry I'm I screaming for a moment on
where someone molecular diagnostics is
maybe two is whole genome Diagnostics as
well and looking at using microarrays to
be able to detect expression levels of
genes so that some of those non-coding
sequences that we were talking about
earlier that can be problematic for
genes can be observed in some of these
microarray technologies they're going to
be very very small sequences of DNA that
are going to be affixed to a chip these
are very very small and thousands of
different gene sequences can be assayed
becoming relatively cheap needed for
detection as well single nucleotide
polymorphisms of known mutations can be
assayed as well as looking for copy
number variants so we can see if we have
some cells that have many many many
different copies of an oncogene that is
what is leading to the proliferation of
those cells we can also use comparative
genomic hybridization to be able to
detect some of the larger chromosomal
changes or copy number variants remember
went on we have unbalanced crampon only
this is only going to be seen when we
have unbalanced chromosomal changes
because we wouldn't have seen an actual
change in the copy number if we had some
of those other on translocations that
would be observed so what's actually
being detected for is extra copies of a
gene sequence and this is very common
commonly observed in certain disorders
I've just listed a couple of here
there's actually several more that could
be included but and hematologic
malignancies the IQF one gene can be
observed in childhood acute
lymphoblastic leukemia it is absent and
so we would see a change in the copy
number compared to normal and in solid
tumors you can see additions
duplications deletions in various
chromosomes what's observed over here on
the on the right is that there are
actually fluorescent markers that are
going to be aligned with and attach to
the chromosomes and then there's going
to be a detection compared to it would
normally be seen and there will be an
increase or a decrease in the
fluorescence of these particular gene
sequences whether or not we have a
duplication or a dilution all of this
leads to the diagnostic mechanism of
cancer is moving much much more toward a
molecular based mark your genetic based
mechanism of testing for these these
changes in DNA as opposed to using Soto
chemical stains or in the autistic
chemistry the technology is moved much
more towards molecular diagnostics we
can use these tools to diagnose patients
if they have this particular lost tumor
suppressor gene make lost hetero
zygosity the people in the laboratory
are going to be in molecular diagnostics
are going to be doing a lot of p53 loss
of heterozygosity testing we can use
that to help diagnose a patient for some
of the gene sequences that might be
fused together we can also use that to
help give the prognosis for a patient a
patient that has a normal p53 status one
day and then a few months later has lost
that heterozygosity we're going to be
using them as a prognostic factor to
determine that they're not going to be
doing so well we can monitor therapies
and the disease process and also help to
detect whether or not we actually have
minimal residual disease or a low-level
obvious issue disease in any of these
patients some of the high-throughput
whole genome sequencing approaches are
becoming far more common in practice and
you'll be seeing many many more of those
processes and technologies in the near
future as well
I will gladly take some questions at
this point and I see that I have a few
on the side there's there's one question
are the single point mutations the same
as SN Keys or single nucleotide
polymorphisms some people do tend to use
those two terms interchangeably
a trio polymorphism is not necessarily
something that's gone wrong in aging in
some instances some single nucleotide
polymorphisms can change the way that a
protein product functions significantly
enough that they can lead toward disease
but a lot of people end up using snips
and foreign single nucleotide
polymorphisms and single point mutations
interchangeably when in actuality
they're not entirely interchangeable
usually when I'm when I'm thinking of a
single point mutation I'm thinking of
the DNA sequence and one specific
nucleotide has been altered well tell me
more if is immutably suggests that it's
an inherited which certainly can lead to
cancer as well but usually a
polymorphism suggests that it was just a
slight change in the activity of the
protein function that the next question
is what is the best way to identify the
fusion transcripts in a tumor sample
well that's a good question essentially
it comes down to what exactly it is that
you're looking for it it's kind of
common practice for particular genes to
meet to detect it in particular ways it
depends upon what assay the laboratory
happens to be using and what
instrumentation laboratory happens to
have on hand or if it's in a research
setting you could be doing any number of
these different assays if it's a fusion
transcript fish is very very useful if
you know what that sequence is because
you have to have a probe for that known
transcript real time PCR is very useful
as well
if you if you have a null and point
mutation is one better than the other in
some cases yes fish is going to be
useful if you have a fairly large number
of cells real-time PCR is more sensitive
you need fewer cells and you are going
to be looking at the single nucleotide
level whereas fish you're going to be
looking at a larger transcript but what
happens with with real-time PCR with
these fusion transcripts is you're
you're bridging where that fusion has
actually taken place so that you can see
the actual transcript or maybe loss of
it at a bit of place within the genome
so what's the best way it depends on
what you're looking for if you're
screaming patients you should probably
be trying to use fish if you know what
that transcript is that you're looking
for if you're looking for a very very
sensitive a say real-time PCR might be
the way to go and and certainly you
don't even have to use some of these um
more high-tech techniques you could also
on be just looking for allele specific
changes as well by using some simple PCR
oh here's a comment mutations have lower
than 5% frequency in the population
since have a higher frequency of over 5%
in the population that's a very good
point indeed a mutation which is why I
say that some people use these two terms
interchangeably when in actuality
they're really interchangeable to be
using but a lot of people do use them as
such poor mutations and snips they can
people tend to use together but I agree
with you exactly that a mutation would
show us less than 5% frequency whereas a
snip is something that's a little bit
more common that we're going to be
seeing at a higher percentage do I have
any other questions
well I will then take you to this last
slide that allows you to get your
continuing education credits
I very much appreciate your interest in
this talk and if you have specific
questions I'm sure my contact
information is somewhere within the
world of bio conference live and I will
happily take any emails from anybody
that is interested in any additional
information and that's all thank you
very much